but british prime minister boris johnson
has admitted the west was too slow to
act over russian aggression in ukraine
and said we cannot make the same mistake
again he became the first world leader
to address kiev's parliament today
echoing the words of winston churchill
the prime minister urged the country to
keep resisting russian invaders
the so-called irresistible force of
putin's war machine has broken
on the immovable object
of ukrainian patriotism
and love
of country this
is ukraine's finest power
[Applause]
well joining me now is renowned putin
critic and former world chess champion
gary casper gary thank you so much for
joining me i really appreciate i'll be
following your twitter feed
uh absolutely assiduously now for the
last two months i think you've been
calling every part of this so accurately
um what is your current reading
of what is happening in ukraine what do
you think putin wants to achieve and
what should we in the west be doing more
thank you for having me again uh i
i think we should separate two things
one is humanitarian catastrophe
atrocities never-ending atrocities
never-ending russian attacks against
civilians demolition of the country
that's all bad news and we all share
responsibility for inaction for so many
years ignoring the fact that for putin's
attack on ukraine was not a matter of if
but when
on the other side we could see that
ukraine army that successfully repelled
putin's attacks at the first stage of
the war and now is defending the east is
about to become strong enough to counter
attack
and i think that with all the support
coming from the west from all
civilized nations
helping ukraine free harm and and also
helping them just to to feed people and
to support the army in any way possible
so uh with this support ukraine will
will win the war and will liberate the
entire country ukraine will be whole and
free crimea included and the way i see
that the liberation of crimea and
ukrainian flag raised in sevastopol
there will be beginning of liberation of
my country russia from putin's fascism
putin has been passed for the free world
well i was going to say the putin has
been repeatedly saber-rattling
threatening to to deploy russia's
nuclear arsenal do you think he's got
any intention of actually doing that
would he want to trigger world war three
in that sense with nuclear exchanges
with the west
i think he's bluffing
uh it's not just his own
own decision he needs enough uh support
uh among rank and piles of russian
military and i doubt very much that
there are many kamikaze
if
any kamikaze at all because they all
understand you know using even tactical
nuclear weapons will not uh terrorize
the west will not put western
governments in panic but it will it will
invite an adequate response and i think
the whole idea of this nuclear bluff was
to um
uh frighten um
britain europe america and and prevent
them from supporting ukraine it didn't
work out and i think uh all the civil
rattling you hear now it's a desperation
it's panic and uh listening to russian
propaganda machine i think they they can
feel that the end is near and and
ukraine army is about to start uh not
just you know holding the ground but
liberating their country and gary we all
know from history that the military
defeat of dictatorship it's it's always
the end of of the dictator well yes and
i absolutely hope that what you're
reading of this is is correct and turns
out to be the case it would be great to
think that would happen for you
personally you're one of the most famous
people
in in russian modern history you were
the greatest chess bar i'm a big chess
fan
and you were by far the greatest most
successful chess player that there's
ever been really in the world
you had to leave russia a place that
reveres sports heroes like yourself
chess heroes do you yearn to go back in
a post-putin russia would you like to go
home
i think it's my duty because russia will
need a lot of work to do to
return to the family of civilized
nations
we have to go through the process of
exaggeration you know same as germany
did 80 years ago and and i think every
person like myself will be very helpful
i believe that i can do a lot to to
help rebuilding my country and making it
part of the global solution and no no
more permanent problem and when you see
gary the furore about wimbledon tennis
at the moment banning russian and
belarusian players from competing at
wimbledon do you agree with the
targeting of russian individuals in
sport and culture and so on or do you
think that that's a misstep
it's a tough question because as you
said you know i'm one of the most
decorated soviet russian athletes in
history
but at the same time understand the
emotions not just ukrainians but
all
but of all all other uh
players by seeing russians taking part
in competitions as a compromise i can
offer one solution any russian player
who is invited and and wants to take
part in wimbledon or any other
competition whether it's chess or tennis
or elsewhere must sign a declaration
condemning criminal putin regime and and
this and this uh horrible war that's the
only condition that uh that's that could
open doors for them if they're willing
to do it you know taking risk then i
would i would argue that they should be
allowed to play but not under the
current russian flag which is the flag
that uh that has been used to to um
carry the war um
in ukraine and the flag uh that's uh
that's being carried by the army are
responsible for
war crimes on industrial scale or
carrying the neutral flag flag of the
international organization or whatever i
will leave it there gary uh fascinated
to talk to you i i do follow your tweets
very closely i think you've been calling
this uh superbly well throughout this
conflict and i hope that your reading of
it is correct and that ukraine
ultimately prevailed thank you very much
indeed i appreciate you joining the show
thank you and glory to ukraine thank you
absolutely